hey guys it was a go against esteem this
is my sister Jenna and today we are
unboxing something really really really
really really really exciting I got this
at Best Buy I did a video for them not
too long ago and I wanted to dedicate a
full unboxing to this coffee maker
we love Kure oh my gosh so I mean I've
been using a Keurig basically my entire
life her entire lifetime my Confederate
coffee drinking life I started in
college which was a long time ago so
yeah this saves my life this is not only
a coffee maker because we never had
several Keurig the different variations
of them we also have the iced coffee
maker one yeah we have the small little
tiny one cup ones but this is a latte
maker
oh you could make a latte this is a
special edition did you know Oh what's a
special okay you can do four cup sizes
you can do a strong brew you can do
coffee shot for specialty drinks
dishwasher safe that's what I like
coffee lattes cappuccinos okay and
that's open yes Oh enjoy 50% off oh look
at that because you a cop Oh for they
know the frothing I'm new to this let's
get in here this is so let's take it out
of the box huge Oh
it is a nice nickel I was so excited
when I saw this is a Best Buy I freaked
out you want the best fine without me I
did I'm sorry I shot a whole video there
without monsters there you're a monster
okay so let's take these little stickies
off yeah this is my favorite part whoa
no my favorite part is the coffee but we
haven't got there yet have you guys
heard this song that goes Jenna do you
feel like I do always forget the lyric
Jenna Jenna do you feel like I do Jenna
how I prefer it are the direction
somewhere giving you the direction we
probably ate the directions that way you
have more sticker Jerry where that's my
bad there's a lot happening get out of
there this is not sponsored by Curie
by the way at all in any shape or form
let's get brewing okay remove the
packaging remove the plastic okay plug
it into a grounded outlet okay what is
that I don't know how big 12 ounces is
but that's perfect actually
just so you know for future reference
that's not 12 ounces well I was doing it
for shock have you never seen a YouTube
video before I have the room mom press
the power button the power light and
auto off light will illuminate it's
illuminating everything's illuminating
the brew will automatically begin
heating the water this will take about
three minutes once the heating stops the
brewer is ready
well I've got our coffee here I also got
this at Best Buy - can you believe it I
bought a fridge at Best Buy I bought my
washer and dryer at Best Buy I will
never forget the guy was like well what
kind of washer and dryer to me do you
need a dryer that hooks up to gas or
electric and I looked at him and I said
sir absolutely big mom this is really
hot do you know how much month to put it
one second probably like four announces
home read all instructions okay we're
gonna make a latte number one to make a
hot latte our hot cappuccino tip having
trouble frothing look there's buttons
there's a phone number to call them I'm
gonna call them should I call them
really quickly I just need to ask I
don't I just need to ask
yes I just got a latte maker I was just
curious is there a difference if I use a
different type of milk great I was just
about to try it so I just wanted to call
and make sure the first that's it thank
you so much I appreciate it you're very
helpful thank you have a great day thank
you for calling here you too bye he was
so nice
okay step one place the mug and pod
let's put this in we're gonna make a
latte so fill this up into the wattle
I'm done yes love gosh oh gosh you're
spilling them no no I didn't spill any
of them you believe me oke cuz I'm gonna
put this down after I'm water wait
that's a lot of milk is this what I get
stomach aches we're in a blockade yeah
lattes have a lot of milk so for as cool
as they should pull myself home latte
cappuccino I have pushed do you think we
should use a clear mud so they can see
you have a clear coffee no Larry I think
that's like a for a wit for whiskey oh
oh it's already going we did it how's
our milk oh um it looks
oh D oh no oh no we forgot to push that
button oh my gosh oh my goodness this
might be the best thing I've ever seen
in my life let me give you guys a little
picture of you a bit over here picture a
picture dictionary have sometimes bought
a video picture of you
it's spinning Oh oh my goodness look at
that
oh my gosh oh oh it's done it's ready I
should give it a little more because my
friend said so it's really upsetting you
yeah I think it is upset with me because
it knew that it's like flashing all the
buttons yeah I think it's ready okay are
you ready for this get freaking height
[Music]
look I'm gonna make you some art okay I
didn't do a very good job of it but I'll
practice have you seen anything so
beautiful before picture this a little
cinnamon oh yes oh no that's a lot of
cinnamon yeah let's get this a nice mix
oh my gosh I'm opening up a coffee shop
- hey Oh what should we call our coffee
shop I call it justine and Jenna's juice
[Music]
mmm hot oh my god oh my god oh my
goodness mmm Here I am imagining that
little bit of cinnamon
right it's lovely
oh my
so the reason that I picked this is
something that I wish that I would have
had when I was in college is because
honestly I spent so much money at
Starbucks and this actually would have
saved me so much money I wish that I
would have had this I I don't know I
know this whole long ago so much boy I
go to Starbucks and I get like a latte
for like four or five bucks but I could
have made my own what tips do you have
for them like if they're just going to
college for the first time cuz Jenna
actually has a forensic biology degree I
just feel kind of crazy I would say that
don't wait into the last minute you
think procrastination is your friend
well it is not don't win too last-minute
I wish I would have been better at
planning other than a coffee maker I
definitely wish that I would have worked
into like Fitness into my college
routine because it is something that
when you go to college it's like oh my
gosh I'm away from home I'm going to eat
all of the snacks and all of the treats
and I'm going to just watch TV and play
video games and I can sort of do my work
try to work that and no matter what eat
healthy yeah the freshman 15 it got me I
know it was a real thing I think I have
a little more than I may have as well
but yeah it's about it's the real thing
so yeah this was great it was really
good Cheers you don't hear it hmmmm oh
enjoy it yeah
well that's it we'll see you guys in the
next video make sure you get scratch on
this channel and if you haven't
subscribed to mine already hit subscribe
and hit the bell hit the bell on Jenna's
channel there's data base ding ding
Cheers you see you guys at our coffee
shop
[Music]